adidas de plata est ce que pour vous il
ya une définition du gîte en nom auquel
ils sont tous pareils ce qu'il y ait un
langage pour les gitans moment je
n'entends 20,9 des résultats qui parlent
beaucoup
c'est le vôtre puisque les prix vous
êtes une villa que vous avez toujours
l'impression de faire partie de notre
visite en mai encore oui je vous
donnerai chanteuse heureusement tous et
ils en profitent
jean paul vi de touche je dois garder
quoi
dans le monde des gitans manitas de
plata c'est l'exception il est riche
très riche bien reçu partout une passe
il attire les foules il paie même
déplacé sous les eaux projet tant les
bohémiens comme on les appelle souvent
dans notre région les amis nepad plutôt
les gitans en ont peu hors de leur clan
mais angoulême ils sont très nombreux
une société d'entre aide existe depuis
quelques mois à leur intention
et on peut situer cette origine dans un
incident qui est arrivé une aventure qui
est arrivé aux jeunes de ma campagne et
qui est un quartier voisin
ces jeunes ont vu un jour sur
la vitrine d'un bistrot interdit aux
gitans ils ont quand même été assez
frappé que à notre époque en france y
ait un somme cette espèce de racisme ils
ont eu tu envie je pense de savoir un
petit peu ce que c'était que ces gitans
ces gens un peu extraordinaire qui était
un peu repoussé de partout et dans le
cadre de la maison des jeunes de ma
campagne
ils ont fait un film sur les gitans sur
le plan juridique m bon scène qu est ce
qu un gitan un gitan et est un citoyen
tout au moins le voulons que ce soit un
citoyen qui n'est pas je crois pour le
moment à part entière puisque chaque
fois qu'il est sur le territoire d'une
commune et il ne peut pas y rester plus
de 24 heures si les autorités locales
décident qu'il s'en aille au bout de ce
délai une loi récente dit que s'il y a
un terrain sur cette commune
le gitan pourra rester sur ce terrain
mais malheureusement ce terrain
n'existent pas partout et notamment il
n'existe pas encore angoulême
si bien que c'est le but premier
principal que s'est fixés notre
association des deux gitans c'est
d'obtenir des autorités qu'il y ait un
terrain et qui soit affinités au non
sédentaires guérin qui serait dotée
évidemment d'installations sanitaires
qui leur permettent d'avoir une vie
décente
je crois vu ben on fait en fait quelques
paniers l'on fait des fauteuils ont fait
des paniers ronds et des sacs à main ont
fait défaut d'en faire et nous a fait
des grands fauteuils ont fait les petits
fauteuils d'enfants ont fait beaucoup de
ferraille aussi du métaux un peu de tout
ce que c'est facile à vendre maintenant
facilement un facilement le sait qu'en
mois pourrait le mieux c en était un
mais en hiver ça plus posséder la saison
morte parce que vous travaillez beaucoup
tous les jours enfin grande partie
en grande partie dans l'espace de
matinée de matinée je fais la valeur de
ces du panier voix c'est du panier est
alors en surplus j'ai ma femme qui
travaille aussi
elle a fait déraper les tout petits et
tout petits modèles quoi ne pas nier la
cia fait toujours s'il fallait sac à
main c'est très fin mais pas envie de
travailler dans une société dans une
usine dans une usine si on demande que
ça travailler en grande partie des chais
où tous les jeunes mais dès qu'ils ont
une tête asseyez quoi ne veulent pas
ceux qui sont les nomades quoi ceux qui
connaissent les bohémiens quoi c'est que
c'est ça qui veulent quoi
alors dès janvier devant une porte
directement laisse encore ça c'est
encore des gitans carrie vladislav ou
pas les embaucher comme valet de rêver
une mauvaise réputation à une nouvelle
amputation oui mais alors surtout que
ils ont une mauvaise mauvaise idée parce
qu'il pense toujours que c'est pour le
coup du bois le poids des gens tout près
des gens ont toujours peur de ça
on dit on dit que vous n'êtes pas très
courageux parce que vous en pensez brad
et le professeur vous avez accompli leur
devoir de citoyen et j'espère me tromper
entièrement mais c'est le monde à
l'envers
j'étais 28 mois d'armée et on n'a rien
moi mon fils moi ça a été en fait
l'occasion pour vous d'être le plus en
contact avec la société offre avec le
reste la salir c'était surtout la en
contact avec les fusils parce qu il est
l armée là on a trouvé des bons qu'on
passe d'armé mais ça vous a pas donné
envie de vivre en fait avec la société
complète c'est-à-dire télévox et société
ça nous déplaît pas mais moyennement
vous êtes père de famille est ce que
vous avez l'impression de rendre votre
famille ont reçu d'ordre possible ici
vous avez des conditions hygiéniques
assez rudimentaire de là un point d'eau
à l'aide de deux points d'eau un point
d'eau kabylie est pas d'ogm on a fait
quoi quelle façon les médecins vont la
couper le tuyau et puis on a reproché
notre 1re vidéo burrata chérir la mode
manouche pas terminé alors qu'elle était
l'évolution depuis les six mois
d'existence de votre association
une toute petite pollution ce sens que
nous avons quelques contacts avec
d'autres personnalités de la ville et
sur le plan humain et une progression
sur le plan humain with free nous les
connaissons beaucoup mieux nous
l'économie
nous pouvons dire vraiment ce sont des
amis nous pouvons aller chez eux nous
les recevons
voyant très souvent je crois que c'est
une très bonne chose parce que vous
croyez qu'ils resteront toujours un peu
en marge de la société
oui et je l'espère ils ne sont pas faits
pour vivre comme nous ils sont plus
heureux que nous il faut les aider à
être re texte
j'avais donc on a l'impression a un peu
envie de faire partie de leur milieu
et m